King Charles III met with President
Biden on Monday for the second time
since he ascended the throne last year
this meeting mirrored a similar one
between the president and the late Queen
in 2021 and continues a long tradition
of anglo-american diplomatic photo ops
Charles may just be getting into the
swing of these things as Monarch but his
experience of U.S presidents goes back a
long way he was just 10 when he met
president Dwight D Eisenhower
his presidential get-togethers since
then have highlighted the importance of
the royal family as vital diplomatic
tools for the UK
but they've also given him a platform to
campaign on issues close to his heart
something he will need to reign in now
that he's King
the future King's first visit to the U.S
was in 1970. America to me and my sister
it was a visit that President Richard
Nixon hoped to be a public relations
Bonanza an indication of the closeness
of the relationship between the United
States and Great Britain and the British
Commonwealth it was one of Charles's
early experiences of engaging in a form
of diplomacy known as soft power soft
power is the power of Attraction rather
than military or financial might and
this is something that the British royal
family really excels at I think public
is very interested in seeing them and so
when Charles came as Prince of Wales he
was much younger and he really had that
star power it was like when the Beatles
ascended because he was this very young
attractive
20-something-year-old Prince he would
later reference that first visit during
a White House trip 35 years later the
media were busy trying to marry me off
to Tricia Nixon that event hosted by
President George W bush also gave the
prince of platform to touch on more
serious matters so many people
throughout the world look to the United
States America for a lead on the most
crucial issues that face our planet he
also praised then First Lady Michelle
Obama's campaign against childhood
obesity and hunger these are marvelous
ideas that I'm sure will make a major
difference and he has not shied away
from using his presidential interactions
to promote issues important to him one
of the great examples is that he did
bring up climate change when he met with
President Donald Trump well we're going
to have a 15-minute chat and it turned
out to be an hour and a half and he did
most of the talking there's been
discussions about why this is but at the
end of the day it might just be more
straightforward and more simple is that
he had the ear of one of the most
powerful people on the planet and
decided this was his issue and try to
convince him to follow suit now as King
Charles must remain politically neutral
and he has acknowledged that he cannot
continue as a campaigner it will no
longer be possible for me to give so
much of my time and energies to the
Charities at issues for which I occur so
deeply I think he'll still press his
issues privately with either the
president United States or his prime
minister and push his own agenda and say
those things and when it comes to being
a soft power tool he has a lot to live
up to the queen was by far the master of
soft power she was a very skilled
Diplomat in many ways and part of that
is because she had 70 years of
experience with Charles we'll have to
see now if he really steps into his
mother's shoes and balance those public
and private outings Charles's Ascension
to the throne comes at a time when the
UK is seeking stronger economic and
security ties with the US the UK really
has to rely on the British royal family
to sort of promote brand Britain and to
keep up U.S UK relations
King Charles may have to cut back on the
speeches but there seems no end in sight
for the presidential photo ops
[Music]